by the way
speaking going now from electric
vehicles to climate change more broadly
we've talked before about this it's
snowed in winter so climate change must
be made up we've talked about that idea
before we've heard it often on fox news
many right wingers love to point out
when it's cold in winter somewhere
it must disprove
climate change part of which is record
high temperatures during certain parts
of the year well tucker carlson is
throwing his hat into the ring on this
tucker carlson in a a segment during
which
he blurts out a string of lies
um seems to say that the existence of
winter disproves climate change the
these people do you think they even
believe this stuff themselves but
they're not laughing anymore
the europeans have discovered that the
real threat to human civilization is not
global warming it never was global
warming the real threat to people
is global cooling otherwise known as
winter
far more people freeze to death every
year than die of heat in 2019 for
example four times as many people died
of cold
as if heat now you that if you have been
watching the show
you know i already debunked that about a
month ago and we'll get back to those
numbers in a moment
that's according to the institute for
health metrics and evaluation so when
temperatures in europe begin to drop a
few months from now this is right
because it's winter huge problem and
that will be obvious to everyone it's
not global warming it's global cooling
that's what's going to kill your
grandmother
and when everyone understands that
perfectly well a lot of things are going
to happen the status quo quo will
crumble factories will close
unemployment will rise disposable income
will disappear it's going to be an
economy crushing dystopia
as soon as all of that happens now much
of what tucker carlson is saying is just
wrong and i know intuitively
maybe that's obvious but let's talk
about it let's talk about
what kills more heat or cold
heat kills more than cold
um if you look globally right i mean
we're a planet here we have an earth as
donald trump we have a world as donald
trump once said
way more people on earth
have the ability to heat their
environment when it's cold than the
number that have the ability to cool
their environment when it's hot in other
words more people have heat than air
conditioning
heat related death over time more than 5
million people die each year globally
because of excessively hot or cold
conditions okay
the heat related deaths continue to
climb
if you ask the question which kills more
extreme heat or extreme cold
you look at the data from noah and noah
has found that on average in the united
states there's
134 heat related deaths versus 30 cold
related deaths on i believe that's a per
capita adjusted number so tucker carlson
is wrong about what he's saying
now
maybe
you think tucker can't possibly be this
stupid no one could possibly be this
stupid and he's saying these things
knowing that they're not true well that
may absolutely be true he may just be
lying it's still really bad for him to
tell those lies but he may just be lying
and it is stunning you know he talks
about europe it's very popular to make
fun of europe if you're an american
right-winger
europe
by and large understands and accepts the
science on this stuff
and they look at the american right wing
and they say what the hell is wrong with
people i understand wanting lower taxes
i even understand wanting less
regulation all things being equal but
denying the science of climate change
that doesn't make any sense
and indeed it doesn't indeed it doesn't
he may be just lying but it's still
really bad we'll have that tucker clip
on our instagram which you can find at
david pakman show
i've seen several people in my life try
to quit smoking or vaping and quitting
has so many benefits but it does require
a strategy and our sponsor fume is a
one-of-a-kind inhaler that can help you
quit smoking as a replacement for the
hand-to-mouth habit of smoking there is
no smoke there is no vapor and there's
no nicotine fume is just a small inhaler
hand crafted from wood it uses cores
infused with fresh aromatic plant oils
for you to taste and enjoy
instead of a nasty cigarette or a vape
you can use fume while flying which is a
big plus because there's no smoke no
vapor no nicotine fume has flavors like
peppermint and conker with a powerful
minty sensation to simulate the menthol
cigarettes they have other flavors like
cozy chai i love chai myself and lemon
berry bliss for a sweeter experience
fume has helped thousands of people quit
people who have tried everything else
read the reviews we talked to the fume
team they're very proud of the lives
that they've impacted throw out the
cigarettes get rid of the vapes head
over to breathe fume dot com slash
pacman and use the code pacman to get 10
off your entire order the link is down
below